اسرائيل لا تقصف غزه والفصائل الفلسطينيه
ترد انفجارات تهز الخرطوم ومدنيون يشكلون
دوريات حراسه نحن سام يتسبب بمجزره مروعه
في هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
نبدا من التطورات في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
حيث تجددت الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه اليوم الاربعاء ماده لمقتل ثلاثه
اشخاص على الاقل فيما ردت الفصائل باطلاق
عشرات الصواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل وبينما
اعلنت القناه الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه ان
الجيش بدا هجوما واسعا على قطاع غزه اكد
الجيش في بيان انه استهدف اربعين منصه
اطلاق صواريخ في القطاع كما افادت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه بان صواريخ من غزه استهدفت تل
ابيب وعطلت حركه الملاحه بمطار بن غوريون
في السودان افادت مصادر العربيه بسماع
يدوي غارات عنيفه للطيران الحربي ودوي
انفجارات واشتباكات وسط العاصمه الخرطومه
مراسل العربيه اشار الى طلعات مكثفه
للطيران الجيش وذوي اسلحه ثقيله شرق ام
درمان نجاه اخرى اضطره المدنيون في احياء
عده بالعاصمه الى تشكيل دوريات حراسه
لتامين منازلهم وممتلكاتهم في ظل استفحال
ظاهره السطو والنهب نتيجه التدهور الامني
في المدينه
من انقطاع مياه وكهرباء وانترنت
من السودان الى تونس حيث افادت مصادر طبيه
بان شرطيا اخر توفي متاثرا بجراحه بعد
اصابته في هجوم اطلاق نار وقع خارج كنيس
يهودي في جزيره جربه امس ليرتفع عدد
القتلى الى سته بينهم المهاجم تقارير
افادت بان المهاجم هو من قوات الحرس
البحري قتل زميلا له في مركز الحرس بجربه
ثم توجه الى الكنيسه حيث تقام احتفالات
يهوديه سنويه وفتح النار على افراد الشرطه
والزوارح قبل ان يقتل برصاص الشرطه فيما
لم تحدد السلطات دوافع الهجوم بعد
في حادثه غير مالوفه وقعت في نيكاراغ
وافادت وسائل على محليه بان سته اشخاص
بينهم ام وابنتها البالغه من العمر ثمان
سنوات لقوا حتفهم بعد تعرضهم لهجوم من قبل
النحل القاتل في اعقاب حادث مروري تقارير
افادت بان الضحايا كانوا من بين حوالي 60
راكبا على متن حافله خرجت عن الطريق في
نيكاراغوا وانتهى بها الامر في منطقه يتم
فيها الاحتفاظ بنحل العسل الافريقي مشيرا
الى ان الحشرات الغاضبه ردت بلسع 45 راكبا
اثناء محاولتهم الهروب من الحافله
والى عالم التكنولوجيا وتحديدا تطبيقات
الدردشه يختبر تطبيق المراسله الفوريه
واتساب حاليا ماذا ينتظرها الكثيرون وهي
خيار تعديل الرسائل بعد ارسالها تقارير
افادت بان مطوري التطبيق يجرينا المزيد من
التعديلات على الميزه الجديده استعدادا
لاطلاقها في وقت قريب فيما تتيح هذه
الميزه لمستخدمي واتساب امكانيه التعديل
على الرسائل بعد ارسالها للطرف الاخر في
محادثات الفرديه او حتى داخل مجموعه
الدردشه على ان يكون ذلك في غضون 15 دقيقه
فقط بعد ارسالها والا لن يتمكن بعدها
المستخدم من تعديلها